this is factually untrue as examples i
humbly submit microscopic organisms
disco and my sense of self-esteem
how's it going it's invisible random
teenage film connoisseur would be
excellent in superhero genitalia since
if this area is protected by the seven
who is still robbing banks and armored
trucks
queen maeve stopped the truck from
hitting the kids awesome wow but she
didn't stop the multiple parts of the
truck now flying towards the kids which
could be equally as dangerous
i'm not sure in a hostage situation that
melting one gun when there's still
another one pointed at children is a
helpful move
are these superheroes corrupt and stupid
considering all of the movies and
merchandising based around the seventh
there is zero chance this asshat doesn't
know that homelander is invincible to
bullets so this is just wasted
ammunition
let's hook you up with thousand meg hdmi
let's go with this one
uh it costs a little bit more but the
carbon's way more conductive upselling
the overpriced hdmi cables
also carbon shadowing
[Music]
don't you ever besmirch
this show spends the first five minutes
investing us in this relationship just
to take it away with one of the most
grotesque and bold holy
moments in the history of tv pilots
right from the start this show knows
what it is and refuses to let up whether
it works long-term or not
this is sin removal territory for sure
in case you confused it with des moines
republic of the former soviet union
using an alarm clock to wake up and
introduce your new character even though
everyone now uses their phone for that
cliche
next we will see her lifting a car and
punching through a wall so why would she
be straining at doing a pull-up
even with one arm also i get that
starlight does have superhuman strength
like the rest of the supes but her main
power is the blinding light thing so why
wouldn't she be highlighting that in her
training montages
you should turn away from the camera and
you should close your eyes or else
i'll blind you shouldn't you just have
her set the camera up and leave the room
wouldn't that be the safer route she
took me to all the little
miss hero pageants but i hated it this
character backstory exposition via
interview is so nakedly forced and
uninspired it might as well be narration
the real superpower here is how tv and
movies have convinced audiences that
people seeing relevant information on
random news broadcast that just happened
to be on a random television with the
volume up is a normal occurrence
i mean it's not as good of power as
flight or invisibility but it's probably
at least above controlling the weather
all you have to do is sign right here
and i'll offer you the check you might
not actually get the check but i will
offer it to you
get the hell out this
character overreacts but gotcha it's
fake moment maybe kind of worked the
first few thousand times
but now i'm so used to it that i just
assume nothing is real and therefore
have a hard time investing in any
character actions at all
it's like that when he saw fable where
the wolf got so sad about the sheep he
was hunting that he just couldn't stop
crying
hello yes this is she
although zero clue how starlight can
hear anyone on the other end with a
hoodie and the sheer amount of that hair
between her ear and the phone this is a
lot of money
huey we could really use it living off
your child
you don't have to fight you never have
i'm sorry but it's it's true
neither do i clearly i mean that sweater
is not the sweater of a fighter
remington steel's on
i think you mean remington steel is
ending considering you're watching
credits unless of course this
up next says remington steel which
wouldn't matter because that wasn't even
there when you said it unless unless of
course it's a remington steel marathon
or you do this every day
in which case that's good enough for a
sin by itself i get that they're about
to introduce starlight as the newest
member of the seven but this is a
shareholders meeting and that is a large
crowd at a [ __ ]
shareholders meeting let's take a look
oh
good even more exposition this time via
promotional video at a shareholders
meeting shows do know they can spread
that stuff out through the season right
a world without crime wait elizalia
tomsu
is both hosting this meeting and doing
the voice-over on the video shouldn't a
big company like this hire a
professional for that
we see a bright future ahead where there
is a vaught hero
in every town but why isn't there
already a hero in every town we find out
that they don't come cheap from vaught
but there seem to be enough around that
it's a common thing i mean what city
wouldn't want their streets to be
crime-free except for boston of course
because
i mean it's boston do they still do
ip-based cereals i thought that was like
an 80s thing
and it really only ever worked for mr t
so this cereal aisle is a lie
also frosted a trains wouldn't it make
more sense for him to partner with an
instant cereal like
cream of weed or quaker oats atrain's
quicker quaker oats seems like your best
bet to me
how are you able to to vanish no i don't
actually vanish my skin
turns into this carbon meta material
that bends the light
like an invisibility cloak more carbo
shadowing and this time through jimmy
fallon
fallon shadowing is always a sin we've
now seen simon pegg and carl urban and
this show is now a chris pine and a
close-up of uhuru's feet away from being
quentin tarantino's star trek movie
this pan around not times square
consists of solely vaught owned
superhero properties do people in this
universe not need cars or makeup or
overpriced broadway shows
the main reason that you won't hear
about it
is because the public don't want to know
about it and that's why i'm comfortable
talking loudly about all my secrets
in the crowded part of the city
[Music]
flies wide shut also levitation sex is
probably supremely disappointing i'm
guessing it has all the letdown
of waterbed sex but without the cool
sloshy sounds
hug my french those [ __ ] that's not
french and you know it
do you know who my favorite musician is
james taylor
number two simon and garfunkel number
three billy joel i would have an easier
time
believing this if the person in question
hadn't been wearing a nirvana t-shirt
this whole time
i'm not as mad that tv continues to
convenience characters into random
meetups as i am that they continue to do
it on park benches who sits on park
pitches those things are nasty and meant
for stupid secret spy meetups or people
waiting for buses with boxes of
chocolates
leaving the seat up that's right taking
a stand on the big issues today bravery
comes in many forms
these [ __ ] pirated my movie three
weeks before release and you can walk
down fifth avenue without bumping into a
table
of unlicensed homeland shirts nothing
makes a superhero show more exciting
than scenes of shareholder meetings and
the heroes complaining about losing
money to pirates
blackwater let's start with you man
noir already means black or dark so
basically this would be like a superhero
named red rojo or blueblow
or ineffective congress the only thing
more unbelievable than this giant
corporation agreeing to this meeting is
that they would willfully hold it in
this room
this is a big building and i'm guessing
there's at least one decent area that
doesn't cause this large of a security
risk
[Music]
it's a good question i would counter
that question with one of my own why
wouldn't translucent stop and question
huey here instead of tracking him down
later in a public place
earlier in this episode all these tvs
were showing the same lion family but
now this one is suddenly engaged in some
more flagrant news position and i know
you're thinking it might be the tv that
fallon just happened to be on earlier
but nope that one's closer to the wall
also i'm throwing in an extra sin for
making me think of jimmy fallon again
we wouldn't dare play the music here but
i'm still giving the show a sin for
being yet another victim of not
realizing there are clash songs not
called london calling or should i stay
or should i go
honestly that's pretty funny but there
is no way aomer expectorated that much
spit in one bloody loogie
translucent doesn't even mean invisible
that means semi-transparent consulting
the urban dictionary
technically i'm not a fade what how is
this surprising
at all to huey we are supposed to be
rooting for this idiot right
there was no baby it was full of cats
hey you know what else we poke fun out
of music videos
some shits have sins too trust me and
we're more than willing to point the
counter at the tay tays the beavers the
billies and many more check out music
videos in today
why don't you shoot him in the head my
name is barry allen
i am starlight i'm 110 pounds and i'm
five foot six
what you doing i should earner hi
um my name's chris parker
i don't know homelander is so he's like
jesus or something
hallelujah you're my savior man
my own personal jesus christ cool
cool cool oh cool cool cool cool cool
you want me to you want me to go to
seven tower by myself
and and you and you want me to plant a
bug like i'm
well like a james bond hey exactly
you're going
and this is the best that you could that
the the government the u.s
government can come up with i mean
you're nasa for crying out loud
i could be like your tech guy you know
like i could be in the van with the
thing hey can i be your guy in the chair
then who the [ __ ] are you i'm batman